Alabama let's move on to some social
media questions we've got one from
Instagram this one comes from Judith why
do we spend so much time trying to be
nice and accepted by everyone else what
compels us to do this and how can we
change it well I don't think the answer
to change it is to start being
mean it's the fastest
option that is I mean that'd be heck of
a mind shift I just wake up today and
just start yelling at everyone here
tired of being nice and it feels good to
be accepted right but but it also feels
freeing to accept the fact that you
won't be accepted by everyone the
Paradox here is that we try to appease
everyone we end up displeasing ourselves
can we talk a bit about that yeah
ironically when a person asks a question
like that that's usually not their
struggle
and really really genuinely kind people
are
rare because it's it's an art form where
they have an inner peace that they bring
everywhere they go and so I don't think
we have an epidemic of too many kind
people have you checked in with Twitter
lately right I'm I'm just saying that
you know um I would love to see an
epidemic of kindness amen you know I do
think sometimes we have um a malady of
of
niceness where we're nice but not kind
where we're U we're afraid so so we
don't act and one of the things you know
you want to make sure that you are kind
but not necessarily um always nice
sometimes you you need to have strength
and courage and uh and and a confidence
that lets you know that you shouldn't be
pushed around and that you have rights
and that there you know you need to be
treated with respect but you can always
do it with Incredible kindness
ironically one of the goals I made in my
life like 30 years ago is I wanted to be
the kindest person in the world and I
didn't make a goal to be the richest
person or the most famous person or the
most intelligent person but I actually
set like my intention in my life over 30
years ago that I wanted to be the
kindest person in the world because I
felt like kindness was a superpower that
you can only be kind if you're actually
dangerous you can only be kind if you're
actually strong if you're not strong if
you're not in a sense dangerous you're
not kind you're just weak I wanted to be
the strongest human being possible and
the kindest person in the world and so I
I I want to say the flip side I want I
want an epidemic of kindness I want us
you know maybe to go overboard in the
way we treat each other with love and
respect yeah I never look in the rear
viw and say I wish I would have been
less kind last month I wish I would have
been less generous now there is a
difference I like you make this
distinction between a nice person and a
kind person a lot of nice people aren't
very kind yeah there's a facade there's
like sort of the big fake smile and it's
saying something to you in person that
they're going to say the complete
opposite when they walk out of the room
or when you walk out of the room and so
they're actually being unkind in a way
because they're not being honest they're
not being truthful with you they are
battering you with their niceness but as
soon as you walk away there's a lot of
the unkindness manifests by the way
everyone here at the minimalist is so
kind you have a a culture of kindness
which I think it's one of the reasons
why you've been incredibly successful is
um I mean you're obviously very talented
and very
intelligent but I I think you you admit
to the world of frequency of kindness
that draws people in and trust you
because of it we love people for sure
and and we we have these conversations
all the time about you how elastic is my
love is it possible to we were just
talking to Sean about this this morning
is it possible to love someone who's a
Nazi and completely disagree with
everything that they believe in that
they care about but it still possible to
be loving to
them I wouldn't be nice to that person
person but may can I love them and maybe
the kind thing to do to that person is
to not simply nod and smile with their
beliefs now it's easy to say that about
that person about the people on the sort
of periphery on the edges but what about
the person you simply disagree with
because they they wear a different
Jersey from you or they vote for a
different politici or whatever it might
be TK what say you your distinction
makes me think of the difference between
being and having I mean uh laughing and
having a sense of humor laughter is an
act I can do it at any time but I can
laugh without having a sense of humor
and I can also have a sense of humor
without laughing all the time right kind
of just the interesting difference but
you know it feels nice to be thought of
as nice and I don't think it's some
great mystery as to why we make a
priority out of it being nice is kind of
like being thought of as pretty I mean
is anyone ever offended when someone
says you look good you look amazing
that's pretty hard to get offended by um
unless they say it in a way that lacks
tack but that's kind of what nice is
like when someone thinks you're nice it
just feels nice the problem with niess
is that it's an external measurement
it's something that someone else gets to
decide about you it's really an answer
to to the question of do you find this
person to be pleasant you don't get to
say if you're nice or not that's other
people's decision I can say I'm trying
to be nice but you get to decide if I'm
nice but I think it life really becomes
something you can take the power back
and you can think about the things that
are in your control am I healthy am I
well am I generous am I anchored in my
values right like I don't want to be
nice it's nice to be thought of as such
but I'd rather be generous I'd rather be
anchored in my core I'd rather be loving
I'd rather be healthy because those are
the things that I can do I can be
thought of as nice but be unhappy on the
inside be unhealthy on the inside lack
generosity but just be good at the
rituals that caus me to show up in other
people's world as harmless Pleasant
unthreatening and so on irn mind shift
three you can't take everyone with you
part of that is accepting that not
everyone is going to accept you and
that's that was a hard chapter for me to
write and one of the things in in each
chapter is that every chapter is
something I struggled with and maybe
still struggle with yeah I don't think
you make a shift and then you're
permanently in that new space yeah at
least that's not my
experience I I go back and forth I'm
like a fan know and it's a calibration
yeah I'm an oscillating
fan I go back and forth sometimes and I
try to take everyone with me almost
compulsively and other people I love
that I you know my life it just keeps
honestly surprising me I I end up with
new ways and New Opportunities and new
expansion and I always want to take
everyone with me and I think sometimes
even people I love have to say to me hey
I don't want to go with you you know I'm
just I just don't want to go there and
because with me like family members when
I have success I want them to have
success and and but success requires a
level of discipline and sacrifice and
and inconvenience and and and I realize
oh I want them to have success but they
see the sacrifice the inconvenience the
discipline required they don't want that
M and they would be happy to get some of
the benefit of the success but they
don't want to take on the infrastructure
for that life the reality is every time
you try to elevate in your life there
are some people who get to tap out they
actually get to tap out from the
momentum of your life and go yeah that's
not me or I don't want that or that's
just that's just too much and you know I
am a i i call myself a soft type A I am
a very driven intense f focused human
being um and I had learned early on
that's not what everyone loves you know
for their life and and I I remember had
this couple he was a Harvard grad she
was a Duke grad so they were like
brilliant and they were Kim and my
friends for you know at least a year and
we tried to really bring them into our
home and befriend them and about a year
later we didn't see as much they're
still a part of our community but I we
could tell they're not as close to us so
I I went to them and I said said hey we
want to talk to you we talked to him I
said you guys are amazing like you're
incredible people but we can tell that
you know you didn't feel comfortable you
know staying close to us they said every
time we're with you we feel that we
should be
more and that level of intensity of
being more we just didn't we're just not
ready for in our life yeah and I said oh
so you you chose to have like a
different friend Circle that wants less
and the go yes and I said I can accept
that like I'm good with that he goes I'm
not even finished
yet and uh I'm I'm not even finished
exploring and expanding and pressing to
see what I'm capable of and and I had to
make the hard psych psychological
decision in my life you can love people
that don't go with
you and you don't have to think of them
as less you don't have to feel betrayed
by them my wife it's like they said
they're going to be with us for life I
said and they meant it in those five
minutes yes yes you know but honey you
know there are some people that you
can't go with because their Direction
isn't your direction and there's some
people that just can't go with you
because your direction isn't their
Direction and we have to give people the
freedom to be who they're supposed to be
and so you can't take everyone with you
even when you love them and you have to
accept that in fact it would be unloving
to drag them kicking and screaming in
your direction no
I I love you for that just admitting
that right I'm going to convince you I'm
going to persuade you I'm going to make
you change your mind but of course a man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion still as Dale Carnegie says
I hope you enjoyed that highlight from
the minimalist private podcast if you
like another highlight check out this
video if you'd like to watch the minimal
episode check out this video or if you'd
like to dive deep into full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast head on
over to patreon the link is in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free